first off thank you for
coming to listen to me ramble on about
javascript meta programming it's a
pretty dry topic i'll talk about it for
about an hour here i appreciate you guys
coming in and taking your time i
genuinely hope you've enjoyed the
conference as much as i have i hope
you've been able to get some uh great
information out of sessions
uh i'd like to thank the
ndc organizers and sponsors for getting
us back together i'm sure you guys are
all tired of hearing we're great glad to
be back together but
it's a lot of work to put on a show like
this and i think the ndc organizers are
world class and just wanted to you know
publicly thank them for for putting
together this and getting us all back
together so
with that
i'm dave i am a
lead software engineer for the back end
of a small company back in
indianapolis indiana called vibinomics
and what we do is
the background music and advertising you
hear in grocery stores across the united
states so there's there's actually it's
not just like somebody sitting in the
back room push and play on on spotify or
something they get sued for that
so there's there's actually a whole
industry behind that and i handle the
the back inside so
i was saying a little bit before we
started mike i came into javascript i've
done javascript years ago in the now
during the browser wars and all that
that was really my experience with
javascript
and
when i started at this company i was a
net developer
i was an i was a microsoft mvp for five
years on uh
visual studio and development tools i
got into that through some of my work
with with f sharp and f sharp changed
the way i program so
if you think about a statically typed
functional programming language
going to javascript
like talk about a paradigm shift right
f-sharp has flavored everything that i
have done
since then
and
when i started at this company i came in
to
stabilize
our old product that's now retired
and i fell i was on contract and i fell
in love with the company so when they
decided that now they would keep me on
to start working on this new project
but the decision was
oh but by the way we're gonna do it in
node
i was like oh that's a little bit of a
shock so but
all of my
memories of what javascript was
back during the browser wars
were completely unjustified because
javascript is not the same language it
was
and now i'm going to approach this talk
from my perspective as a node developer
so if you're primarily front end i think
you'll be able to get some mileage out
of this but i don't do front end
developments so i can't really talk to
how it plays with the various compilers
or babel or any of those
i'm sure you'll be able to use most of
these leverage most of the techniques
but i have not personally tried them
but yeah so if i was doing
javascript the way it was during the
browser wars i think i would have
changed careers
but now with es6 we have so many robust
capabilities
that
it is absolutely a different language
than it once was
and one of the things that i think
really has has evolved and matured over
the past several years is our ability to
do meta programming so who's familiar
with the idea of meta programming
okay so half the room
so
we always hear about metadata but meta
programming
is programming about programming so how
can we make our code
understand itself and adapt and evolve
itself that's what meta programming is
and when you understand
what meta programming can bring to your
project you can think in different
levels of abstraction
and generalize things that would
normally be more single case single use
opportunities so
for this talk we're going to go through
a number of the techniques that are
available to us
in modern javascript but we're going to
start going way back in time
so with that
we fall into now three categories for
meta programming the first is code
generation
and i'm gonna say right up front i never
do this
in javascript javascript doesn't really
need it it has capabilities for it they
all suck
uh
the first one the obvious one eval
don't use eval right
yeah i don't
i'm not going to go into
the discussion on why not to use eval
it's well documented
even the mdn documentation says don't
use this
use some other things instead but the
idea is
you give eval
a string of javascript and it
throws it out to machine code and
compiles it every time you need to do
anything with it every time you run eval
it needs to do it there's no keeping it
around so
it also has some
scoping issues and whatnot but yeah the
idea is give it some code it runs it
don't use it
let's skip through this and i'm and i'll
say that a lot of these early examples
and the historical things i'm going to
kind of gloss through because it does
get a little repetitive but it's all
building up to some of the ways that we
can apply the modern interfaces to
make our code a little bit more more
self-reflective so to speak
so then
we don't use eval we get the function
constructor a similar idea
solves some but not all of the issues
with eval
i have yet to find a need to do it
just based on the nature of javascript
but
it does isolate your scope a little bit
better and it doesn't it doesn't form
closures around things like you would
potentially see with eval
but yeah you call it the function
constructor you pass it the parameters
that it's going to accept and the
function body and it takes care of the
rest and then you can treat it like
another function hey surprise new
function gives you a function
but it doesn't close around things as i
mentioned so if i have const name
outside of my
function constructor it doesn't have
visibility into that so the output of
this
is going to be name is not defined so it
gives us that little bit better
isolation
and for the node developers
we have the vm module
which
suffers from many of the same problems
but it does give you some better
isolation than the function constructor
or
definitely eval
not going to go into this a whole lot it
is just another option for how we can
dynamically add code to our system
where things start getting interesting
in meta programming
is in the idea of
reflection or introspection so this is
looking at your objects what is the
structure of your objects what data
types do they use
and how can i manipulate those so we've
always had
some capability for this
in javascript
the in operator is one of the oldest
operators in the language
got an object defined it has three
properties first name last name and age
and then i can use the in operator
first name in my object well yeah it is
i can see it last name in my object yes
it is middle name no it's not
and in has another use
probably seen the structure where we
have a four
variable in
this allows us to look at all of the
properties on the object
so if we run that and we push
all of those property names into an
array
we get an array of those property names
hey surprise
but we can take it a little bit further
even in the old days of javascript we
could use that for more practical things
than just saying what is on here we
could use it to copy values around now
all
references and pointers and everything
else that come into play are still a
factor but if you're needing to
transform an object perhaps or
change from one model to another that
was a particular way to do it it was a
little bit more verbose than the ways we
have today
but it was certainly an option
we could remove properties with the
handy delete operator
i was asked why would you ever need to
delete a property
one of the cases i've had is
the system that i work on is primarily
event driven and we want to capture when
a user has
changed certain aspects of their user
profile one of those aspects could be a
password i don't want to capture the
password on my event log so i strip it
out before it with something similar to
delete before i write that model to the
database
and delete does exactly what you'd think
so then if we have age and we
delete age and we delete middle name
which doesn't actually exist hey look
but but delete returns true anyway
like that so that's one of the
shortcomings of delete because it's
it did something well no it didn't but
it completed successfully so therefore
it definitely deleted something
but age we had defined
we deleted it
and now age is no longer in my object so
that one at least tells us the truth
and start to see a theme with some of
these older
interfaces these older operators and and
statements that you'd see
in the very early days of javascript
type of
you need to understand
do i have a string do i have an object
do i have a function
that's where we go to type of
last time i said those people got on on
twitter got mad at me
type of lies
now it doesn't really lie everything up
here is is the best kind of correct
which is technically correct but you
have to understand more about how
the
value was initialized then one would
necessarily think especially if you're
coming from like a.net background
and you ask for type of you expect it to
give you a consistent answer but if
depending on how your value was
constructed in javascript type of can
give you something that is only
technically correct
type of string gives a string but type
of string constructor gives us object
now if we're in our own code base
we can control for this right we know
we're not going to call the constructor
so we can be pretty assured
that
type that if we call typeof and our
value is a string that we should see
string
but i know that we don't all work in
silos we don't always have our own code
we pull in npm packages all the time how
can you be assured that what you're
using for what an npm package is giving
you is constructed in the way that you
construct everything in your code base
so
type of
while it can be useful
is generally best avoided and i i
personally use the
functions from lowdash to do the same
thing mdn has um some discussion about
the
pragmatism of typeof and it actually
provides an alternative implementation
that you can use which i looked at it
looks pretty decent but i use lowdash so
i didn't care that much
but if you need to understand what your
data types are
type of may or may not give you the
answer you're looking for
so
we looked at these things we see that
there's maybe some problems with some of
them they did what they were supposed to
do but not necessarily as predictably as
as one would like especially me coming
from a functional background i like to
make sure that i have things like
referential transparency so i want to
see that if i call a function or if i
delete a property and it's going to tell
me that it deleted something i want it
to have actually deleted something
so we come in
to a new round of things we get a whole
new series of functions most of them
hanging off of the object type
we get things like define property
where
rather than just manipulating the
contents of the dictionary or hash table
whatever you want to call it the the
object where you can just dynamically
attach things we now have an entire
interface for how to define that not
only do we get to control the name of
what we put in this object
we get to control various aspects that
the
interpreters and the runtimes understand
so
things like the enumerable property
which controls
if you were to do an in against the
object
whether it is actually listed or not
you can control that aspect you can make
them read only
and as you'll see later there are ways
to
control how you get or set those values
we get a nice function called get own
property names so anything that is
innumerable
on that object
will come back in an array so if we call
object get owned property names on this
object
we see that we have the two that were
defined
on the object itself directly and then
the next two that were added
programmatically
through the reflection operations that
are defined on object
and similarly
we have keys off of object
which are the ones that
are
so actually i'm sorry get on property
names includes the non-innumerable ones
and keys is just the innumerable ones if
we look at define property for middle
name enumerable was false it is not in
the keys
so there's a distinction between those
two and i missed that i apologize
and let's see we already talked about
that piece i'll skip over that again
part of this gets a little repetitive
just watching this this evolution so
property descriptors i talked about
enumerable a bit i talked about writable
we want to provide the value well that's
conveniently named as value
and configurable i can't remember what
it does i meant to look it up because i
i don't remember
i have not had an instance where i
actually needed to set it so
generally i just leave it at the default
but we saw a little while ago they get
on property names and we saw keys well
we can also do object.values
and so this will iterate over
the properties on there and give you the
value of them and not just so instead of
getting the name you'll get the value
i'd find things like this being useful
if i'm trying to convert to a csv for
instance i can get the property names
once and then i can get the values on
each object in my array
provided they're the same structure that
can be convenient
but where things start getting really
interesting
is bringing back both of those pieces of
data the keys and the values together
so define our object the same way we've
been defining it add a couple of new
properties
then we have the entries function
the entries function
gives you
an array where since we're calling map
an array of keys and values
which you can then
work operate against with operate
against as you please so in this case i
just map them into a string and join it
on semicolon and so the output of this
is first name is dave's last name as
fantasy ages 42.
so we can get those pieces of data we're
starting to see things about how our
code is structured and the values
associated with that structure
and if you've done
this or you've got entries maybe you've
written that off somewhere
and you want to reconstruct your object
well you get object from entries on that
which does the opposite direction it
will recreate an object based on those
key and value pairs
so you don't have to do it manually
and i think in this one yeah so then we
get
object assign
so given some object
put other put the properties and values
of another object into it
so in here i've got my object
and i've got an empty object
and i pass in my object along with it
and we get
a new object
that has the copies of the first
object with a new
value being added into it
so when we've done the clone we do
object assign we start with that empty
object this is the object we're going to
put stuff into
and then we're going to
copy those values whatever is on that
other object that's what's visible from
that object gets added onto this new
object
which paves the way for merging objects
and that's object assign so we had
object assign here with an empty
now we have object assign with something
with some values in it so maybe you have
two different data sources that have
parts of a data structure
and you want to put those back together
well
object assign i have
core object properties like some user
profile perhaps and then maybe some
posts it's an array i can merge those
together easily through
object design
and these are great like all of the
things that we've talked about the
hangout of object are great they're
incredibly useful but in es6
we get yet another api
that takes a lot of the lessons learned
from those
object-based functions
and gives us
some a bit more
consistent interface if you will
and these are all defined in the reflect
type
so there's a lot of overlap between what
we've seen on the object functions and
in reflect and in fact many of these
like the define property
have the same signature
they take the same parameter so if we
look at this instead of calling object
defined property we're calling reflect
depend define property we're telling it
what object to affect which one we're
going to mutate
what our new property is and then we
have that descriptor
with our configurable true enumerable
true and our value
and it does exactly the same thing but
it does it in a little bit more
consistent way it gives you uh that the
differences are really that i think and
i kind of forget which one does which
off the top of my head
one of them throws a type error the
other doesn't i i
meant to refresh my memory on that but
they behave
differently and in a little bit more
predictably as you're working with them
not and because i'm an es6 and these are
available in es6
i tend to favor these over anything that
i saw and talked about on object
and
so while object didn't have a
delete
features there's no object.delete
property
there is a reflect delete property
this behaves more consistently than the
delete
keyword that we looked at before so if
you need to remove a property reflect
delete property will do that for you
reflect get reflect set
so we're just looking at
the functions that control
reading and writing to properties
i never use these
they're kind of redundant now
they tend to make code a little bit more
verbose because those they said it's
javascript i can go and do a dot and an
equal and and we accomplish the same
thing
so i don't tend to to
use these but they are there and it's
nice to be aware of them
but enumerating properties remember our
friend the in operator
this is the basis of how
i write a lot of my introspective code
on my platform
this serves a very similar purpose of in
except that it gives us an array of
those properties so
in here i've got
similar structure that we've seen before
i did use the object version of define
property here but reflect own keys
against my object gives us that array we
don't have to do a for in
to get these values anymore we just get
the array
and if we have an array that means we
can map against it we can reduce against
it we can filter against it
that leads us into all sorts of
composability possibilities
that
can change the way that you structure
your code
similarly within we have has so reflect
has my object in the property name give
you a true or false
as i was saying we get into this
composability
so i have this function here
this
is a very naive implementation for
demonstration purposes only
but
this is a way that we can start building
some more generalized functions for
handling validation
and keeping
our logic separate from our data
as a functional programmer i don't want
to
merge
functions and data in classes and all of
that pollution that comes with classes i
want to keep these separate i want to
treat data as data and functions
sometimes as data but usually
independent of the models
so in this i've got a
higher order function and that's that's
important to that because this this
leads again to composability so familiar
with higher order functions
okay i don't see so there's a lot of
hands that didn't go up so higher order
functions are functions that accept or
return another function think filter
think map
and
think reduce the one function to rule
them all
pretty much everything that we have in
the in terms of these array
functions whether it's map whether it's
filter whether it's sort it's all a
reduce that's all it is they're
specializations of reduce
so
this function called validate model
accepts a validation model which is just
an object that has some
some properties but instead of having
values of actual data values they have
functions as values
and then it accepts the model that we
want to validate
and we use
reflect own keys against our validation
model to know what properties we want to
validate
and we reduce against those essentially
looking to see if
the value in our model
satisfies the predicate from the
validation model
we'll see an example of this on the next
slide
if we have any failures we throw an
error and and we don't proceed
otherwise we return the model
so a helper function
and then an implementation now that
higher order function comes in into play
here
so we're calling validate model and
we're passing in
not the data that we want to validate
but the way we want to validate that
data
i've written that validate
model function exactly once
because the act of validating something
is almost always exactly the same thing
we know we have
some rules
that our data model needs to adhere to
in order to
enter our system
so now i've codified the rules
i have first name needs to be a
non-empty string last name needs to be a
non-empty string and age needs to be a
number
so again naive simplistic but this is
the basis of of how i structure my code
with
and using these meta programming
techniques
so what is
the
validate person model anybody
what what is the value of the validate
person model at this point
it's a function
okay because validation model goes to
model goes to
so it's a function that still wants to
accept our model
so we can invoke validate person model
giving it our actual data model
first name
satisfies is not empty string last name
doesn't
and age
is a string so it's going to fail and
hence validation failures
are last name and age
i can take code like this and hand it to
a non-technical person and say are the
rules right and they can say
if i've named things properly and
understandably they can say yeah that
looks right or what are you thinking
there's some power in that because the
code is now more expressive because
we've abstracted away all of the extra
stuff that we have to write
all the boilerplate stuff we have to
write to
express what rules are in our system we
now just have a list that follows the
structure and we'll come back to this
example a little bit later
oh actually i think
i just jump into it now let's do that
switch this
okay
nope
yes
all right let me blow that up
is that visible in the back
all right cool thank you
so this is an extension of that example
that we just saw the code is the same
i added a couple of extra things into
here so i'm using i'm in visual studio
code now and what i'm using to drive
this is
a as an extension for vs code called
quaka i know if you've heard about it
but it's a fantastic tool it's
essentially a repo for javascript that
gives you some additional testing
capabilities and
just an all-around really useful tool so
we've already looked at the validate
model this is again the same code as
before
but we can apply the same concepts to
transforming our data
so say that we have a a
web page somewhere somebody's filled out
a form and the browser provides the
data in one structure but we want to
transform it to a different structure we
can use these reflection techniques
in a very similar manner to what we just
saw with validation to do the
transformation as well
so this particular function transform
model i'm sorry
yes so transform model they're starting
to see a pattern here we have
transformation model goes to model goes
to reflect
this time
we're reflecting
on the transformation model and we're
reducing against those keys so if i've
defined a key
on
the
transformation model
it will appear
in the target the new newly transformed
model
so we're going to project our model from
one structure to another
and the body of that is get the
transformer
get the source value define a property
on the target model
just iterate over those through reduce
as reduce does and return it
so then i get two
functions below i do a i define a
function validate user model which hey
that looks familiar i changed it from
age but it's uh it's birth date now
and we have transform user model
there's a theme here
i have first name last name birthday age
and what do they take what are their
prop their values their functions
in this case the value so as we try to
read a value with the same name off of
the input model
we put pass it in as value
and we also provide the source model in
case we want to have something else
from that source model available
in our transformation
when we see the code in a minute that
runs these two together we do the
validation before we do the
transformation so we know what if we
meet our validation rules
we know that we're in a structure that
we can transfer that's safe to transform
and then we can apply the transformation
so now transform model first name oh
we're just trimming it we already know
we've got a string because it passed
validation so we can just trim it
last name
okay trim it and go to uppercase because
arbitrary reasons
birth date we can convert to a date and
we can take the format if it was in one
format we can translate it to another
that's all i'm doing there
and oh why not let's just calculate the
age too while we're at it
so we don't have on our user model
a first name property a last name
property
or an age property we do have fnamelname
and birthdate
so we can see the validated model is
what we saw before
and transformed model takes that
validated model
and applies the transformations i'm
going to run this
and we'll see in the output window
the
top group here
is the result of our validation
and then the
bottom
object
is a result of our transformation
does that make sense
okay i'm going to jump back over to
these slides for a bit
all right
hello
okay apparently uh
the presentation and the display got out
of sync when i did that all right there
we go
so who has encountered symbols in
javascript okay only a handful so
guy doesn't count
symbols are one of my favorite things in
es6
so what symbols allow us to do is define
a
they're they are a guaranteed unique
value let's start there so you are not
going to have a collision
with
something else
naming something the same way because
every time you create a symbol it's
unique to javascript to that to that
instance in that environment right
they are intended as extension points
essentially so
you hear things you know prototype
pollution
evil right
well and i think back on my time in
in earlier days of javascript and well
no don't extend certain things because
you're going to have a collision with
some other proper or some other library
is going to name something the same way
and everything is going to step on each
other and the last one in wins
symbols work around that problem
so we can attach we can define a symbol
and attach it to an object
and then we have a safe extension point
on that object
so in this case say we just do symbol
it's a function not a constructor
we can pass in an optional label helps
identifying it in the debugger that's
about all it does
uh
kind of lets you differentiate as you're
as
writing things out in in console and
look watching its
various traces and and whatnot
it does carry that description with it
but that's about the only value that
that serves but it's generally nice to
attach it just so you know what you're
looking at in the code
and
there's the global symbol repository i
believe that's what it's called
where you can register symbols to
be shared more
commonly across code so then there's a
there's a use case for that that we'll
get to in a little bit
uh so when we can define our own global
symbols we can toss our own symbols into
yeah into the repository so this one i'm
calling symbol four this is the the four
function puts that in the repository
and if i do a
comparison if i say global symbol which
i've just defined is actually equal to
the one that's in the repository if you
were to have something else you just do
symbol without calling for
and go my global symbol that is not the
same symbol every call to symbol gives
you a new symbol
so simple case for using these
define a symbol which i'm just labeling
as greet
and
i have a function called say hello
i'm going to attach say hello to an
object with a bracket syntax
because it's a it's an expression value
it's not a it's not just a name it's
actually
the key is the symbol
and then we can invoke that function
as
we would any as we would reference
anything else more dynamically just put
it in brackets make it look like an
array
this case isn't really all that
practical just to shows how you can
attach one of the ways you can attach a
symbol and and what the symbol is useful
for
but they are an integral part
of modern javascript because there's a
whole series of what are called
well-known symbols
and these well-known symbols
are for the dot-net programmers in the
room very very conceptually similar in
use to how a lot of the built-in.net
interfaces are
because they drive
a lot of the the syntactic sugar
things like modern in are driven by
symbols and you can customize how your
objects behave with things like split
and search
by
tapping into the well-known symbols that
the modern javascript runtimes know
about
in this case
i'm using the well-known symbol which is
exposed as a
as a static
property of the symbol type it's called
two string tag
how many times are you debugging
something and you see object object
and say wow thanks a lot javascript i'm
glad you know what that is
tostring tag
is one of those well-known symbols that
is actually understood
inside of the javascript runtime
that controls
how that string is constructed so
instead of object object
i'm attaching symbol to string tag
through reflect define property to my
object
and the get this is part of that
descriptor for that property the get
function
returns just
the interpolated version of two of the
properties so instead of object object i
get object with my name in quotes
that's more useful than object object
now i'm able to make more sense of the
code i know exactly what i'm working
with
and all it did was take attaching a
symbol to it
so one of the things i really like to do
is abuse language features
i never i have i've yet to find a
language feature that i
didn't like to abuse symbols are one of
them
and
did anybody go to mark seaman's talk
yesterday
so mark seaman talked about
fractal architectures and trying to keep
your construct your code in such a way
that you
limit
the complexity of your functions to
essentially what
the typical human can keep in their head
so the usual the mantra of
seven plus or minus two right
well as we start
building out our systems and they become
more complex it's nice to be able to
reduce that surface area and i think
symbols
in javascript are a great way to do that
so take this function another higher
order function
attach symbol
accepts a target and a function and then
it returns a function that accepts a
function that does something returns a
symbol
we create our symbol
we attach it to
our target object through reflect
defined property
it's not enumerable
it's not writable
not configurable but the value is just
that function
so just like what we did
back here we're just doing this as a
function so we can start attaching
symbols that are just defined as we need
them
and we'll return that symbol so now we
have a reference to that symbol
which allows us to do things like create
a function called attach symbol to
object prototype
which the target is object prototype
and because everything comes from object
prototype we can make things more
generally available throughout all of
the objects in our system
and
from my
functional programming background
i like the pipe
oh i like functional pipelining
i want to take
a value and let it flow into a function
and let the output of that function flow
into the next function and so on
i don't want to write code where i have
to name variables
or constants that have a life cycle or a
lifespan of one line of code because
that's something else to keep track of
so i can just
i can attach a symbol
to the object prototype i'm going to
call that symbol pipe and refer to that
as pipe throughout my code
it's pretty simple now
it's a function
that takes a function and returns
the result of applying whatever object
has been extended
where pipe was originated
applying the function to that
any ideas why i'm using
the function the classic function syntax
here instead of arrow functions
sorry
this exactly
this is the one place i use a classic
function extension uh or use a classic
function like
in in most of my code i avoid
any type of of scoped functions because
that just leads to temptation of
writing code that is deep that has
implicit external dependencies and and i
don't want that as a functional
programmer i want my function to be
given directly and explicitly everything
it needs to do its job and give me a
value back
in a predictable manner
so here as i attach that symbol
now i have my object
pipe was already attached to object
prototype so as it tries to resolve that
name it's going to go up the tree up the
prototype chain it's going to find that
symbol
and i'm passing a function in
which does some transformations
and this is essentially writing a log
message
but i don't have to keep track of that
intermediate stage
because i know what my input is
i know what my transformation is i can
transform it again and i can transform
it again and it's just a step of
operations and there's no capturing
variables because we already have a
variable defined for these things right
it's not on the screen
but this
is the variable what we would put it in
so we just let it flow into the next
part of the chain
it reduces that surface area
okay
so if we go back to
vs code what am i doing on time we're
doing
right
pretty good it looks like
let me go back to vs code and we'll
revisit that last example
so that example we just looked at
with
transforming and
validation
we have
our validated model which gets the
result of validate user model and we
have transformed model which we could
then which gets the results of
transforming the model and so on
by applying
that
function
extending
object prototype with that symbol
we get rid of a lot of those extra
variables and things we have less to
keep track of and again we've got us
just a checklist of things the series of
steps that our code is running through
we still have variables and parameters
in place
but it's allowing us to
define things in a way that is a natural
flow
and nothing in here is is non-standard
javascript like this symbols are part of
es6 right
all of the reflection capabilities we
didn't bring we didn't use npm to bring
anything in those are all things that
are just natively part of
javascript
reflect own keys
gives us that ability to look inside of
our objects and see
what is there
and apply
operations to either those
keys directly or obtain the values
related to those
we do that same thing over and over and
over then that's half of what
programming is it feels like we get some
value we got to do something with it
right
this allows us to get those
generalizations and we know that we're
applying things in consistent manner
okay
all right let's see if i can do this and
not have it lose my state
there we go okay
so that's largely the reflection and
introspection part but then we have the
third
part of the metadata triangle and that's
intercession
so intercession is where
while
reflection is acting upon
the data and understanding the structure
and and
working with that structure intercession
is actually intercepting behavior and
doing and manipulating the built-in
behavior
uh before es6 there really wasn't a
whole lot of capability for this but es6
gives us a little bit more
capabilities here i actually should have
just stayed in vs code i was thinking i
had another slide
so
the es6 gives us
some additional capabilities and we've
seen some of this and i forgot to extend
what's going on come on duplicate there
sorry about that
so object defined property gives us some
of that intercession capability we saw a
hint of it earlier when we saw get on
something
when we define a property
using define property that's the reason
i like to use define property instead of
just saying dot some new
identifier
because we can control those aspects
we've talked about enumerable but get is
when we read a value
what happens normally it just gives you
the value back
if it has it or it gives you undefined
what happens when you call when you try
to set a value well normally it's just
going to put it in the dictionary or
update whatever is already there
but through
define property we can define get and
set and control what that behavior
actually does
so in this case i've got a
object function called audited object
inside of that function it's tracking a
context and a log so what this is doing
based on its name oh we're going to
apply some auditing here
i want to know when people read
a value or write a value
and you could redirect this as you would
see fit in your code i'm doing console
log for demonstration purposes
we can see when we
get a value from an audited object
we'll log out getting context first name
and then we'll return the value of first
name
from that context object
likewise when we set it we provide the
value
you see here
we log out that we're changing that
value
we set it on the context
and then we push that change to our log
so not only have we written out to the
console log we're managing a
history of what those changes were
i think that's pretty common
so i defined that as first name and then
i defined it
very similarly on last name
and then i defined a property called
history
again against this
and
here we only have git we don't allow
setting history because what good is is
history if you can rewrite it
so that we can create an instance of the
audited object and i'll run this in a
moment so we can see it we can write out
we can get the history and this is the i
meant to mention this earlier the
slashes and the question mark is quacka
and how it will automatically log things
out when we run it
we can see what we call
uh where we set the first name and the
last name we write them out
and so we're going to see a bunch of
logging that goes along with this
so let me do this
run once
so we got a bunch of things written out
to the console on that one
just as we expected as we defined on the
get and set for each of those associated
properties
setting context
setting context getting context
wrote it out
and here's the history so we can see all
these changes that we've made that we've
captured as we've as the code was
executing
and so on and we can see every single
thing we did to it was
written to the logs
and this would be powerful
but
do you really want to write this over
and over and over and over for every
property because i don't
i would never do it this way oh
but when you're doing diff when you're
doing defined property you get that
flexibility but
it's really cumbersome to to manage over
time
so
that's where es6
gives us
the proxy object
proxy object and remember i talked about
consistency in interfaces earlier
es6
gives us the reflect
type and it gives us the proxy type
and they have exactly the same structure
they have different different intentions
behind them
but there's a one-to-one relationship
between the functions on
reflect and the functions on proxy
where on the reflection side it's about
looking and controlling what the objects
are
whereas on the proxy side it's about
hooking into those behaviors so if you
were trying to call set you may control
what set does
in in the classic way with setting get
and set but you don't really get into
some of the the other
capabilities
that
the proxy can give you
and the thing about proxy
is that it just it does what it sounds
like it does it wraps up an object
and it hooks into those things as you
provide
those particular properties to hook into
so where we had to in the previous
example define
a getter and a setter on basically
everything we wanted to put on there
now
with a proxy we can define it more
generally
so now i have const audit object and it
gets an object and we still have the log
that we were seeing before
but instead of
returning a constructed object
we return a constructed proxy object
and we provide an initializer to the
proxy so we provide the object that we
want to proxy so whatever we want to to
monitor intercept the behavior of we
provide that object
and then we provide
get set and there's a whole series of
these again they correlate directly to
what is available through
uh
through the reflect so if we wanted to
intercept defining a property or
removing a property we could do that
so here
get takes the target and the key
set takes a target and a key and the
value right pretty self-explanatory
it's exactly what you would expect for
those behaviors
and we do basically the same thing now
one of the things that i think is really
nice and and they did a good job with
implementation on is
proxy knows what object it's proxying
and it's not and so there's a potential
for a little bit of an infinite loop
because if i'm going to intercept the
behavior on an object and you then go
and do perform that behavior on the
object
it knows that it's already doing it on
that object so it's not going to just
keep cycling through it
so
we're going to extend this which then
becomes the tar so the object that we're
passing in
is essentially the target on each of
these
and so these functions as they run
they're going to operate against the
object
but in that context and so they you
won't get caught in any of those vicious
cycles
in this case
we detect what property we're trying to
set and whereas in our previous example
we
specifically defined a history property
well we don't have to define the history
property here because it's
doesn't exist at all it's just a proxy
we're faking it
so if somebody tries to
set the history object
we're going to say you can't rewrite it
otherwise we're going to do exactly what
we did on everything so now we have
arbitrary extension and it doesn't
matter how many properties we want on
there or what those properties are this
behavior whether it's get or set is
going to kick in for all of them just by
the nature of that proxy
and using that object is essentially the
same as what we had before so i've got
audit objects and i'm wrapping up just
an empty object we'll try to get the
history we'll do the first name we'll do
the last name we'll write it out same
steps as we had before
getting history from target it's empty
setting first name setting last name
getting first name
and if i scroll down here well now
age
undefined
where'd i get there getting age from
target well it was undefined
we see that here
so then but we still captured it we
don't have an age on our object we
didn't define it before
we've defined it now so we can set a
value on it but it wasn't there before
but yet we still got the behavior
of getting age from target and setting
age on target
because the pro the proxy handled all of
that for us
yeah so
one final example here using the proxy
is
i mentioned we can look at other
behaviors so similar type of of example
but now
oops
we're hooking into delete property and
has
so just like we looked at on reflect
earlier where we can reflect delete
property or reflect has we can proxy
delete property and proxy has
and run that
again notice here
we set first name we set last name
so we see that behavior
scroll these a little bit
we set first name
and we set last name
get first name get last name now scroll
through a little further let's go find
it in here
that reflects delete property
and now
there is a delete property
in here and we can see deleting age from
target
and we have a series of has
looking for first name oh it found it
looking for history found it looking for
middle name
didn't find it because we never defined
it to begin with
so
code generation
not so useful in javascript
reflection introspection incredibly
useful in javascript and proxy depending
on your needs could be useful in your
projects
so
i want to thank you all for your time i
hope you found this
useful and interesting even if you don't
take it right away i think that
javascript has has definitely come a
long way in these capabilities i know
that they have certainly
changed my opinion of javascript in the
number of years uh definitely has
matured as a language and i think this
has a lot to do with it so i thank you
for your time and please enjoy the rest
of the conference